-And finally,
have you guys noticed
that when you start
typing something on Google,
it automatically tries to
complete the search for you?
It autofills
what you're looking for?
Sometimes their suggestions
are a little off.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for Google Autofails.
-♪ Google autofails ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Just look at what I did today.
I typed in
"How did Yellowstone..."
and these three things
popped up.
"season 4 end?"
"get so popular?"
"convince my dad
to start dressing
like Woody from Toy Story?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
He works in an office!
Here's another one.
I typed in
"Why is Joe Burrow..."
It said "so good,"
"number 9,"
"in my wife's search history?"
[ Applause ]
-Wait, what?
-Next up, I typed in,
"How to return" and it said,
"a package to Amazon,"
"cable equipment to Spectrum,"
"Prince Harry to England."
They --
-That's not you.
That's an autofill.
-After that, I typed in,
"Why can't I sleep?"
and it said,
"through the night,"
"on my back,"
"without scrolling through
TikTok for three hours first?"
"I'll just check it,
just real quick.
I'll just --" Pretty good.
Next up, I typed in
"Whatever happened to..."
it said "Amelia Earhart,"
"Susan Boyle,"
"Predictability? The milkman,
the paperboy, evening TV."
[ Applause ]
After that, I typed in
"How to survive..."
It said "a tornado,"
"a hurricane,"
"a fight in the bathroom
with Marjorie Taylor Greene?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know.
How do you do it?
Next up, I typed in
"Why do the Girl Scouts..."
and it said,
"sell cookies?"
"wear sashes?"
"guard the entrance
to the grocery store
like they're
the National Guard?"
You going somewhere?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And finally, I typed in,
"Am I the only one without..."
and it said, "a 401k?"
"a car?"
"classified documents
in my garage?"
That's all for Google Autofails.